ses quartiers dans les tentes ouais
la pression commence à monter
eux-mêmes ce soir
à la place des filets
benjamin baisse charge des roseaux
[Musique]
ce ne sont pas les gestes habituels pour
un pêcheur mais c'est pourtant bien le
rituel de la fin de l'été
de grosses responsabilités pèsent sur
les épaules de ce jeune homme de 29 ans
il est responsable avec une poignée de
volontaires
du barrage de l'ayrolle
une étendue d'eau poissonneuse qui
communique avec la mer
les hommes sa ligne sur une borne à
terre puis se positionnent autour d'un
rectangle
une fois par an les pêcheurs kadri la
mer sur près de 3 km de longueur
il progresse ensemble des places leur
rectangle de cordes et à l'aide de
roseaux des limites des parcelles
parfaitement identiques
[Applaudissements]
en fin d'après-midi les alignements de
roseaux devant la mer traces deux lignes
parallèles
à l'intérieur on y installera des postes
de pêche
fils et lui pièges à poissons une fois
les temps paraît le dispositif va leur
assurer une source de revenus pendant
quatre mois
nous sommes tous les trois sont guère
entré depuis le mois de février mars et
vénus à bien se nourrir dans les étangs
des qui sent les eaux de mer et ce qui
sera rafraîchi ce qui sort le mauvais
temps ils préfèrent partir regagner le
lait font les grands fonds comme les
barrages servent à maintenir une partie
du poisson on va croire qu empêcher
qu'on pêche une petite partie
en attendant de commencer le travail à
la mi septembre
les pêcheurs doivent se répartir
119 parcelles
autant de postes de pêche au rendement
bien différents selon les courants la
profondeur la nature des fonds marins
alors pour éviter tout favoritisme
c'est un tirage au sort qui va décider
de la répartition des postes
présage
heroes tim et tu vas jamais le tirage au
sort une règle fondamentale de la
prud'homie des pêcheurs de gruissan une
institution puissante née au lendemain
de la révolution
dans ses registres et consignés toute la
vie des pêcheurs
le partage des territoires de pêche
les plaintes les procès verbaux de
conflits de sanction ou encore l'état de
la ressource et le détail des espèces de
poissons
[Musique]
22 promettre chacun pense que chaque
section
aujourd'hui les prud'hommes sont élus
pour trois ans par leurs pairs
issus de cette longue histoire benjamin
est le plus jeune élu de la prud'homie
de gruissan
la distribution des lots a toujours lieu
le soir du barrage
premier louis mas
à deux pas de là où il allait la mener
dans cette pièce tout le monde est au
courant
papa il y à beaucoup plus de mauvais
poste que de bons à distribuer
ayrault
mais chacun croit en sa bonne étoile
quitte à brûler quelques cierges
mise en boîte de rigueur dans cette
communauté qui se connaît par coeur et
si cela permet d'effacer les tensions
on sait être si bon joueur patricia a eu
la main heureuse benoît et benjamin
alors
pas de pitié pour les prud'hommes
benjamin est un pêcheur comme les autres
l'an dernier j'ai déjà été gâté et cette
année aussi donc pourvu que ça continue
moi mon tirage les moyens ni bon ni
mauvais loin de bomber musique dans ma
carrière fait moi ça fait
26 ans que je fais la pêche j'ai déjà eu
tous les bons postes au moins trois fois
chacun c'est pas la peine
ce soir pas une voix ne contestera le
tirage au sort
respect et discipline
deux règles d'or de la communauté des
pêcheurs de gros isme
[Musique]
lorsque la chaleur accable les flots de
la lagune père et fils se retrouvent
pour une pêche en duo
ici c'est le paradis de l'anguille que
l'on capture avec une cape et chad un
ingénieux montage de filet et de nass
amarré au fond de l'eau la communauté
des pêcheurs s'est elle même fixées
règles et interdiction alors là ça m de
paradis à ton appel à un guide quand il
a tapé dessus elle peut pas se prendre
et je suis d'un côté ou d'un autre ou
après un peu ça retourner aussi mais
c'est à chaque extrémité après un piège
il ne cacha dans
ces deux là toute petite maya
est fait pour pas que le passage
justement le petit passe aussi près nez
et que nous on verrait pas et qui après
vers le but est justement juste qui
suivent pour se prendre rentrer dans le
coeur
et se prendrait restait alors que une
fois qu'il est dans la panade il est
vivant il bouge a pas de problème et
comment bien tous les deux trois jours
régulièrement visités et le passé nous
procure à pantani ne souffre pas
comparer ma au travail
parade hier pente and cap et chad
l'ensemble vue duo dessine une flèche
bien connue des étangs de méditerranée
les poissons vivant glisse sans stress
jusqu'à la pointe
[Musique]
vous
elles auront beau se tortiller les
anguilles se constitue prisonnière et se
retrouve maintenant en compagnie de
quelques grammes hinault fasse rire
[Musique]
ah ouais ouais ouais voilà
ça c'est beau
c'est de la belle anguille imputation
jolie même aujourd'hui parce qu'avec la
chaleur et les pêcheurs nous ramassons
toujours plus jolies les langues
isabella terme
chaque pêcheur a droit à six filets pas
un de plus sous peine d'amendé de la
prud'homie qui sur ce point est plus
stricte que le cadre européen
et un de nous mêmes on voit qu'à cause
de la chaleur l'anguille commencent à
souffrir est tout ça de nous mêmes en
tant que pêcheur et les prud'hommes
décideront de lever les filets et je
n'ai pu l'empêcher ça je trouve ça et
vous allez écouter oui parce que je
pense que les pêcheurs sont aussi
dépendants de l'anguille si on peut
payer toutes langues et la pêcher pour
la tuer même pas pouvoir la vendre je
pense que ça ne sert à rien c'est du
gâchis
ce n'est pas tous les jours comme ça
mais disons le tout net aujourd'hui la
pêche est excellente sur le retour père
et fils active le réseau
et bernard antony 6
minutes maxi
le mareyeur est déjà sur place il faut
aller vite car l'anguille est un poisson
fragile
vivante elle est vendue entre 4 et 8
euros le kilo
et pendant six mois de l'année elle fait
vivre les pêcheurs de l'ayrolle
signatures dont 133 kg gecina cède pas
mal là cette direction sète d'aller dans
les bassins est après ça va à
l'exportation en espagne et au portugal
ça c'est pour le circuit classique
mais benjamin a choisi la modernité il
ira là où sont les attentes en circuit
court
à peine 16 km direction l'une des
meilleures tables de la région
[Musique]
exceptionnelle
c'est même du pain béni pour le jeune
chef laurent chabbert amateurs de
produits régionaux et de saison
là je vais lever l'anguille
bangui de benjamin on a de la chance on
est là belpech
des anguilles correspond bien grosse
comme ça je vais les mettre sous vide et
du véhicule en fait à la vapeur entre 10
et 12 minutes environ
on va rajouter
les carottes du potager du gras de porc
un peu champignons une bonne chose rouge
bien réduite à ses côtés
et voilà le travail passer de mains
d'experts à main de maître
en guise de l'étang de l'ayrolle en
croustillons d'ail des ours déclinaison
à autour de la jeune carottes et son jus
de matelas
[Musique]
le glissement de mézin
glorifié en son temps par charles trenet
gruissan et ses habitants s'apprêtent à
chaviré ce week end
fin juin la ville fusionne avec sa
communauté de pêcheurs
le 29 on célèbre la saint pierre et ça
commence la veille par une grande
sardinade dans la cour de la prud'homie
chaque année il ya un engouement énorme
pour cette était bien on le verra demain
est un monde de fous qui vient pour
célébrer et prier pour quoique marié
décède pour connaître leur sort et
s'était raté un engouement qui prennent
tout leur sens et ça fait plaisir à voir
parce que pour une fois le pêcheur et et
moi
ce soir le pêcheur invite le village à
sa table et demain le village lui rendra
hommage
c'est un attachement viscéral
inter générationnelle
en bois on voit tous les jeunes des
petits pics de famille de pêcheurs que
chaque année qui leur tiennent des mcr
est bien de donner cours bénévolement
c'est quelque chose que pour moi
émouvant quand même qui me tient corée
qui fait plaisir le thème en 5 et je ne
vienne avait nous l'ont ça leur plaît je
dis peut-être après nous y aura une
autre génération se connaissent tâches
qu'on espère vous pas que la prud'homie
c'est fini c'est
[Musique]
pour la première fois de l'année la
chambre de saint-pierre est ouverte
à cette ancienne figure de proue
repêchés en mer par des marins
gruissanais on peut désormais
murmuraient des prières des voeux vous
confesser dépêché une ferveur singulière
tombe sur la ville
10h du matin rue de la prud'homie
l'heure des discours les officiels de la
région sont présents en uniforme des
préoccuper de l'étang de campignol jean
jacques sébastien benjamins ont revêtu
la robe et la toque des prud'hommes
et au même moment dans l'église
donc pas
on pense
aux immigrés
fabrice n'est pas un fada non le chef de
musique répète ses gammes car dans moins
d'une heure les pêcheurs vont
interpréter ici même le fameux scottish
[Musique]
c'est une danse qui à l'origine
viendrait de d'allemagne qui se ruinent
german paule ka qui sera arrivé dans les
années 1840 1850 à paris puis après
partie sur l'angleterre alors qui sait
peut-être là bas les écossais ou marin
écossais se serait peut-être qu apparaît
donc et puis bon c'est pour que la
raison est arrivé jusqu'ici
[Musique]
tout à l'heure l'église sera trop petite
pour accueillir tout le monde
10h45 st-pierre prend son premier bain
de foule
[Musique]
e
aux premières mesures de la fanfare on
célèbre enfin le patron des pêcheurs à
tue tête avec ce champ que tous
connaissent et attendait depuis l'année
dernière
[Musique]
je
ni dormi dollars et dont c'est la
surface la seule femme issue récit mire
et puis regarde le public y présentent
leur façon de danser chacun a la sienne
qui est assez particulière certains ont
plus chaloupé que d'autres d'autres des
petits pas d'autres un peu plus rapide
[Musique]
comme prévu sous la baguette de fabrice
les travailleurs de la mer s'élance dans
une église pleine à craquer
[Musique]
on
au bout de l'allée il embrasse
l'ostensoir
puis au nord saint pierre et surtout
saluent leurs trois représentants
[Musique]
cette danse païenne restitue le pas des
marins en mer
et dans ces instants d'émotion intense
croyants ou pas chacun a sa vérité
l'impression qui connaît une bénédiction
au dessus de nous que notre bateau coule
pas que quincy des chiffres qui nous
arrivent pas de malheur notre pied ne se
prenait pas dans un filet dans des jours
de mauvais temps voilà on est quand même
il ya ce petit rythme missionné par un
ami qu'on est une petite étoile au
dessus de la tête
[Musique]
et celui là poussent bien loin à la
symbolique de la chaloupe ceir aux vieux
briscards mystique
la scène bien pensée servane crise
spirituelle
en fait la bougie c'est la lumière qui
guident un peu la barque de la vie
[Musique]
héroïque le réveil gruissanais a joué
cette année 42 minutes sans interruption
le scottish gruissanais a encore
bouleversée l'assemblée
à la mémoire d'un parent ou d'un proche
certaines n'ont pas retenu leurs larmes
est certain aussi d'ailleurs
à l'idée que denis le pape à partir à la
retraite et danse peut-être pour la
dernière fois
[Musique]
on
ea n'a tellement fière de filmer son
mari benjamin et son pitchouns elie
sûrement un pêcheur celui là
dans quelques années
[Musique]